congratulations thank you after seven
Emmy Award wins this is your first
Golden Globe win how does it feel
different
it feels pretty great I I have been here
a number of times and never won so it
feels extraordinary I feel really proud
of this one I feel proud to be in in the
the film arena and to be singled out
from my individual work I've been a part
of so many great movies but never in
this way to be recognized and it feel
pretty proud and especially having a
friendship with the screenwriter for so
many years is extra special and
meaningful for me in this moment it's
wonderful
Allyson Angela Bishop from Network 10
Australia congratulations thank you yes
well Margot yes she's all ours we'll
take the credit for it what was it like
for you can you talk us through working
with Margot Robbie on this project well
you know it's funny I've gotten to know
Margot a little better promoting this
film because I literally had no I was
doing mom and and rehearsing for a play
on Broadway six degrees of separation
that I did and I I had no I literally
had to hiatuses I had to fly to Atlanta
and I shot each week four days and then
went back to do mom in Reverse and come
back and shoot eight days a shot in this
movie and Marco and I had no time to
spend hanging out and getting you know
when she wasn't working on set with me
in a scene she was preparing for the
next scene or working on her accent or
working and she had so much on her plate
and I just watched her and admired her
courage and all this I can't even
imagine taking on it's just I love the
story of Margot not knowing this was a
real story when she read the script just
like man this is a crazy story how did
you come up with it and Stephen was like
it's actually a true story and I just
loved her bravery taking on an American
iconic sports figure like Tania and just
watching her tear it up she's an
extraordinary woman I loved watching her
I've so much admiration for her hello
Alison directly in front of you hey
hello have you obviously we just saw
that Tania just it recently did an
interview how she reached out to anybody
on the cast or anything about this movie
and she of this
order of the film being produced he's
here tonight she's social table yeah oh
she totally sitting out there at my
table she loves the movie I don't think
she loves all of it
as she told Stephen himself she spent a
lot of time with Stephen Rogers and and
you know she agreed to let him take her
story and tell other other characters
stories from their point of view but
she's and think she's pretty proud of it
I think she should be I think I mean we
don't exonerate her but I think that she
comes out looking okay in this I think
people have a lot more understanding and
compassion and empathy for her what she
went through and what she was up against
and what she achieved in spite of it
she's I think she's a huge supporter and
she's out there tonight I should have
brought her back back here with me
Allison over here to your right to your
right congratulations first of all Thank
You Margaret with KNX radio The Times up
initiative has been huge tonight here at
the Golden Globes there is some concern
I've seen some reports that things may
just go back to the old days the way
they were to the boys club so on and so
forth what is it going to take to create
sustained change well we're talking
about this with some other friends of
mine saying how I don't know if we'll
ever be able to end abuse and sexual
harassment but I think that people now
will be there'll be repercussions for
that kind of behavior people will be
held accountable for it I think with
this times of the the the fun they're
creating is going to help people who
might not have access to legal to legal
defense
get counsel and and I just think
there'll be more accountability I don't
think we can ever eradicate the abuses
of power those have been around from
since the beginning of all time and but
I just think it just won't be tolerated
anymore and hopefully the the
repercussions for it will make people
think twice or go get help I don't you
know that's what I'm hoping
Thanks